what's with the jeans I don't want to
overdo this theme but do you want to
make your special announcement or don't
you think it's time for you should
notify have you although with an all
aboard
that's for people who are like I listen
to the show on speakers in my cubicle
goddamnit yeah there's porno and shit
talk give you a little warning although
it's kind of a late warning
it's already started yeah alright so
this is something that really happened
and it's so substantial mage subsystem
substantive that you know we're stopping
the show essentially yeah alright guys
here goes March 3rd at 7:22 p.m. I
christina pazsitzky had a double pipe
classic it's pretty amazing
thank you it is a maze thank you thank
you you were sitting there describe it
yeah I describe the moment for me
because I was living in I didn't really
wanted a really you know you were
holding our child yeah what a really
special a more special moment than I
even recognized you were holding our
child and I was sitting only a few feet
from you hmm I was distracted and you
said Tom and I was like hold on I think
I was reading man you talk of what you
go I just had a double pipe classic and
I dropped my phone I dropped my phone on
the ground I said why and I said what
time is it
you did market you wrote the time down I
mean what was it like you know people
ask because we've had people email about
them and yeah tweet you know a guy even
came out to me had to show his
girlfriend he was like I had double pipe
classic this week and his girlfriend was
like so disgusting
and I go I said that's really special
it's like yeah it's a Halley's Comet of
body functions yeah you don't because me
have somebody who's obviously
well-respected in the body function game
you know I mean they happen literally
once maybe every five years maybe really
they're not they're not common yeah no
because you have to everything has to go
just right for a little bit to go up in
a little bit goes down yeah it picks a
path like 99% of the time
well yeah you're right and the reason
that I have it does on it but sorry
interrupt sure can go it's not burp fart
it has to be which is the hard part now
luckily my anus has loosened as I've
discussed due to childbirth and I think
what happened was the burp happened and
usually I have more fart control but
because I've lost fart control BAM yeah
and it happened and you know when you're
in the moment you're in the game yeah
you don't realize it until a second
later maybe what I don't maybe I don't
know really
will this be a more common thing oh
because of the pregnancy
in which case does it count as much of
course it counts is it what okay maybe
you know they're not as genuine that's
not true Tom don't you rob me of this
gift
look childbirth ravaged my body
pregnancy ravaged my body the one gift
nature gave me was the gift of farts now
yeah okay uncontrollable bowel movements
that are uncontrollable yeah I'm going
to enjoy this wonderful gift okay
okay well you know I'm just I'm just
thinking out loud you know yeah how dare
you try to take the validity of my
double pipe classic from me well you
just brought to my attention that things
have changed don't shake your head
I just feel dare you rob me of my joy I
think that it's fair to bring it up to
discuss it that's all it's sort of like
you fuck you okay Jesus you heard what I
said